left in this third quarter oladipo  utilizing the screen  gets the open look  [Music]  collins fights for the offensive glass  gets stripped away brogdon  tries to heave it down court touch pass  to warren warren up and under  gets the foul on yusuf nurkic  and warren will head to the free throw  line here that time indiana  with a big screen to stick cj  you can pick up the audio that's my  favorite part about this whole  experience now  listen i understand there's no fans  we're gonna miss that for sure but  some of the chit chat as i like to say  from the players on the court  that stuff is gold right there it's gold  to you  and a lot of people watching the game  but the nba they're losing sleep over  at night if you start really  going into some of the things that are  communicated on the floor but that's  part of this experience it's different